Here's the Ensemble Learning algorithm. We're done,
Michael, we're done with the entire lesson.
We don't have to do anything else anymore. We know that we're supposed to
look over subset of data, pick up rules, and then combine them. So, what
else do you need to know in
order to write your first Ensemble Learning algorithm?
>> So, I'm already kind of uncomfortable with this notion of"
combine," right? So, like, I can think of lots of really dumb
ways to combine things. Like, choose one at random or, you
know, I don't know, add em all up and divide by pi
I mean so, so presumably there's gotta be
some intelligence in how this combination is taking place
>> Yes, you would think so, but your not
at all bothered about how you pick a subset?
>> Oh ,I was imaging you meant random subsets.
>> Oh ,so you'd automated assumption about how we were going to
pick a subset. You just [CROSSTALK] weren't sure how to combine them. Well
actually let's explore that for a minute. Here's kind of the dumbest
thing you can imagine doing. That turns out to work out pretty well.
We're going to pick subsets, by, I'm going to say uniformly. Just to
be specific about it. So ,we're going to do the dumbest thing
that we can think of, or one one of the dumbest
things you could think of. Or maybe ,we should say simplest and
not dumbest so as not to, to, to make a value
judgment. That you can think of doing which would be to just
uniformly randomly Choose among some of the data, and say that's
the data I'm going to look at, and then I'm going to apply some
learning algorithm to it. Is that what you were thinking of Micheal?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, so just pick a subset of the
data, apply a learner to it. I'll get some
hypothesis out, I'll get some rule out. And now
I'm going to combine them, so since were being simple. Why
don't we try doing something simple for combining. Let's
imagine, Michael, that we're doing a regression. What's kind of
the simplest thing you could do if you have
ten different rules which tell you, how you should be
predicting some new data point? What's the
simplest thing you could imagine doing with it?
>> So, okay, so each of them spits out a number. I guess if we kind
of equally believe in each of them, a
reasonable thing to do would be to average.
>> Great. So, a very simple way of combining, in the case of
regression, would be to average them. We'll simply take the mean. And by
the way, why wouldn't we equally believe in each of them. Each one
of them learned over a random subset of the data. You have no reason.
>> Well.
>> To believe
one's better than the other.
>> There's a couple of reasons. One ,it could be a
bad random subset. I don't know how I would measure that.
>> I could be a good random subset.
>> Yeah. Then we'd want, we'd want that to count more in
the mean. But, but I guess what I was thinking more in terms
of maybe for some of the subsets you know, it gets more
error than others or it uses more complex rule than others or something.
>> I could imagine that. Actually maybe we can explore how this sort of idea
might go wrong. Let's, let's do that. Maybe we can do that with the quiz.
You like quizzes, right?
>> They're important.